[Música]
bom eu sou hotel isso na pan-américa
desde o p3 e atualmente no g8 então ano
passado e vi uma reportagem sobre um
grupo de amigos todos ciclistas que
arrecadavam tampinhas de plástico e
trocavam por dinheiro na reciclagem com
este ano eles compravam peças e essas
peças com cinco bicicletas adaptadas que
ajudavam na inclusão de deficientes
visuais no ciclismo
eu lembrei que eu gostava de brincar com
estas tampinhas quando era criança e um
dia até que entrar para o livro dos
recordes mas eu desisti porque eu sabia
que alguém já tinha exposto agora
percebo que o pedal inclusão tem um
vestido bem maior é bem mais importante
que quando tinha quando criança de
juntar tampinhas
então eu fiz contato e eles me aceitaram
como voluntário e nós queremos uma
relação muito boa e muito forte
eu comecei a participar dos eventos de
inclusão social deles e com isso eu
comecei a perceber como é importante que
nós fornecemos nós proporcionamos esses
momentos de alegria felicidade e lazer
para pessoas com deficiência seja motor
o visual e percebi também que nós temos
que reclamar - e dar mais valor à vida
por isso o período de inclusão está de
parabéns porque é um grupo que
diferencia que é que não fala mas que
realmente faz e por isso estou muito
orgulhoso de fazer parte pela inclusão
agora vou passar a palavra para o lance
no vídeo que é um dos membros pela
inclusão pra continuar falando muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
obrigado hotel
quem aqui já pedalou então você deve
lembrar da sensação de vento no rosto
a sensação de uma corrida com os amigos
na rua da frente de casa
a sensação de liberdade a primeira saída
de casa com a volta na quadra essa
sensação gostosa que a bicicleta
muitas vezes nos traz bicicleta além
disso ela traz hoje eu pedalo com amigos
no hotel falou é um grupo de amigos tão
quando encontram um ciclista quando é
ciclista encontrou um ciclista na rua
não é um desconhecido por mais que não
conheça ele passa pelas mesmas
dificuldades no trânsito os mesmos
prazeres as mesmas experiências que a
gente tem todos os dias então ciclismo
trouxe muito mais pra mim do que o que
eu sentia de vento no rosto de perder
muitas corridas ganhar algumas trouxe
muito muito mais coisa nos últimos anos
mas vamos deixar isso um pouco de lado e
vamos falar um pouco sobre exclusão
quem é que nunca teve a sensação de ser
excluído ser excluído na escolha de um
time de futebol na escola seja excluído
em uma festa que não foi convidado
porque não era famoso na faculdade ser
excluído por não ter dinheiro para ir
naquele restaurante fino uma época mais
difícil
vários motivos de exclusão agora tem
gente que sente isso todos os dias
tem gente que quando pára na frente de
uma escada não consegue subir
tem gente que quando acorda de manhã e
abre os olhos não enxerga
essas pessoas todos os dias tem algum
tipo de exclusão seja serão seja serem
excluídas da sociedade seja serem
excluídas de coisas que a gente faz tão
comumente que nem percebe e são
excluídas por nós mesmos muitas vezes
nós os excluídos
até pouco tempo atrás eu não tinha
amigos ego
até pouco tempo atrás eu chamava
deficiente visual
eu não falava que a pessoa era cega
até pouco tempo atrás eu chamava o
cadeirante
eu olhava de longe o cadeirante eu não
sabia como me aproximado um cadeirante
de um cego como tocar como falar como
respeitar como conhecer mas teve um
momento onde eu cheguei disse que tem
alguma coisa errada comigo nesse jogo eu
preciso fazer alguma coisa mais eu
preciso dar algum sentido pra isso tudo
o que eu estou sentindo eu preciso
movimentar alguma coisa for uma série de
perguntas que eu acabei me fazendo sobre
esse essa grande exclusão e foram
momentos onde eu me identifiquei com os
excluídos não por alguma dificuldade
física ou motora mas por questões
psicológicas financeiras das mais
variadas possíveis que o que certamente
o pessoal do rondon e isso muitas vezes
né
então eu comecei a questionar o que eu
posso fazer em relação a isso e aí
desses questionamentos
surgiu a oportunidade da gente montar o
pedal da inclusão e da inclusão é uma
associação que visa mais do que levar o
ciclismo pra pessoas com deficiência é
trazer pessoas com deficiência para o
ciclismo não quero fazer um passeio
consegue
eu quero que o cego participe do de um
passeio tem grupos de bicicleta saindo
todas as noites por porto alegre
por que um cego não participa disso não
tenho certeza que não é porque tá escuro
ea gente conseguiu através do pedal da
inclusão fazer muita coisa bacana não
prossegue não para o cadeirante mas para
nós mesmos
eu me dei conta que o pedal da inclusão
não era a inclusão de deficientes no
ciclismo não era inclusão de ciclismo
para o deficiente mas era inclusão de um
novo conceito na minha vida era inclusão
de uma era exclusão de uma diferença que
eu tinha que eu sentia até aquele
momento
essa aqui é uma foto do primeiro passeio
que a gente fez com o pedal da inclusão
a gente tem ali uma bicicleta um tipo
modelo chamado também de dois lugares
onde uma pessoa é um vidente um ciclista
que enxerga vai na frente ea senhor um
deficiente visual uma pessoa cega que
não enxerga tendo a oportunidade de
pedalar
ele já pedalou antes alguns deles
nasceram cegos nunca tinha tido
oportunidade de pedalar
outros perderam a visão proença o
acidente no meio da vida
acharam que nunca mais pedalava logo
depois disso aqui isso aqui na avenida
ipiranga quando a gente entrou na gift
paramos numa sinaleira e eu tava eu não
tava numa das bicicletas também estava
numa na minha bicicleta como batedor
ajudando a parar o trânsito para uma
sinaleira e do meu lado matando em com
um alguém pedalando e um cego atrás e
toca o telefone do cego
ele atende desliga e começa a rir e
começa a rir numa risada que ainda hoje
me arrepia é era minha mãe ela não
entendeu nada disse que agora não podia
falar porque estava pedalando é é um
cara né e só sentindo só estando lá pra
sentir o que eu estou sentindo agora né
isso aqui faz um ano e meio talvez para
trás e eu não esqueço disso nunca mais
eu não esqueço do que eu senti nunca
mais e mais do que isso eu sinto hoje o
que eu sentia aquele dia a emoção de
estar havendo uma foto e lembrar daquele
momento isso nunca paga em mim que
enxerga e pedalo se fosse só que
aparecer pra minha mulher ela vai
reclamar pedalo todas as noites é
mentira faz tempo que não pedala mas que
têm a oportunidade de pedalar todos os
dias eu me emociono ainda hoje e ele que
não tenham não tinha tido a oportunidade
de pedalar por tantos anos e voltou a
fazer isso nunca mas nunca mais vai
esquecer de fato e essa aqui é lilica
a lilica é professora de séries iniciais
é tá conosco pedalando no nosso grupo
junto com o nosso grupo desde o primeiro
pedal
a lilica ela começou pedalando numa
também atrase e o prazer fantástico
delicioso e um dos projetos seguintes do
pedal da inclusão a gente conseguiu essa
bicicleta adaptada de uma cadeira de
rodas vai na frente e pela primeira vez
ela teve a oportunidade de ter a
estabilidade em cima de uma bicicleta e
um quase um deficiente mental
já eu com toda a coragem que deus me deu
sentei na cadeira de roda é um louco
sentado na frente uma cega pedalando
atrás né
e eu me comprometi a fazer isso com ela
na avenida ipiranga no próximo passeio
passando pela joão pessoa pelo túnel da
conceição pela avenida mauá
a lilica pedalando e eu sendo os olhos
dela nesse momento não não tem como
dizer a sensação disso não não existem
palavras de comunicação nenhum nenhum há
nenhum p
sai pra falar o que tô sentindo é
oportunizando isso pra lilica e assim
como a lilica tem vários outros
amputados e senhores de idade
várias outras pessoas vários deficientes
uma mãe com um filho com paralisia
cerebral podendo dizer o seguinte fazia
tempo anos que eu não tinha como fazer
um evento com alguma coisa com os meus
dois filhos juntos porque um já não quer
mais a mesma coisa que o outro e naquele
momento estavam os dois filhos
pedalando e são vários modelos de
bicicleta que a gente tem é o tandem
onde a gente pedala com cego ou não
precisa ser cego com pessoas que têm
dificuldade de estabilidade é um modelo
onde uma pessoa com deficiência motora
cento e pedala com a mão ou outro em
caixa a tua própria cadeira de rodas e
pedale então são vários
várias formas da gente fazer esse
processo de inclusão várias pessoas
fazendo esse processo de inclusão mas
tudo o que a gente precisa pra fazer
alguma coisa necessita de dinheiro é
bacana é bonito mas é caro comprar uma
bicicleta também de mil e quinhentos
reais
é caro comprar uma bicicleta adaptada
para a cadeira de rodas
são coisas que demandam de uma parte
financeira ea gente encontrou num modelo
de arrecadação de tampinhas essa esse
formato
pra gente é conseguir a gente arrecada
tampinhas vende e compra as bicicletas
através de uma tampinha
eu odeio ressignificado pressa tampinha
essa tampinha pra mim hoje ela
representa inclusão social de um
deficiente e minha que vocês estão
fazendo
obrigado
[Aplausos]